du nord au sud aucun pays d'europe
n'était pas reniée par cette vague de
chaleur les prévisions pour la semaine
prochaine ne sont pas vraiment optimiste
en espagne cette canicule a causé la
mort de 4 14 personnes françois jullien
pieds-noirs 35 degrés en suisse 41
degrés chez les italiens et même 48
degrés sous le soleil espagnol
l'europe est à l'heure de l'union
caniculaire dans tous les pays de
l'europe de l'ouest
on bat des records
dans les rues de florence l'accessoire à
la mode c'est l'éventail il faut chasser
les 41 degrés quotidien mais c'est en
espagne qui fait le plus chaud 45 degrés
enregistrés à séville une chaleur
brutale mais une chaleur qui tuent aussi
quatorze personnes sont mortes en
espagne dont 11 en andalousie
plus à l'est les croates doivent
supporter une sécheresse record
de quoi affaiblir les personnes les plus
fragiles au monténégro le danube révèle
ses secrets léo entend baisser que des
bateaux de la seconde guerre mondiale
semble renflouer les glaciers suisses
alpin supporte aussi mal la canicule la
glace fond jusqu'à 4000 mètres
d'altitude entraînant chute de pierre
rey avalanche et même en norvège les
rênes investissent les centres-villes à
la recherche d'un peu de fraîcheur